ein verlassener komplex ende eine
alaskas
wegen des harschen klimas ist die anlage
ganz schön heruntergekommen aber hier
muss noch etwas anderes heftigere es
passiert sein
die rostigen überreste von krieg und
unterdrückung
man spürt regelrecht dass diese
verfallenen gebäude und züge teil einer
leidvollen geschichte waren
wie ein dunkles geheimnis das jetzt
hinter lang versteckt wurde
ein eindrucksvolles symbol für die
wiedergeburt einer nation
das ist schon merkwürdig
einerseits wirkt die anlage ultramoderne
und futuristisch gleichzeitig hat sie
aber auch etwas altmodisches
rückwärtsgewandtes
und ein wall aus beton szenen in der
eifel
als ich das erste mal in diesen wäldern
war fand ich es total unheimlich hier
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie oft
gegeben
[Musik]
in der kleinen ortschaft whittier im
süden von alaska steht ein gigantischer
beton komplex
[Musik]
inmitten einer atemberaubenden
landschaft taucht plötzlich dieses
winzige dorf am fuße eines berges auf
ein bauwerk springt angesichts der
malerischen kulisse ganz besonders ins
auge
das gebäude wird total überdimensioniert
seine gesamtfläche entspricht der von
vier fußballfeldern
hinter zerbrochenen fenstern und
vereisten treppenhäusern liegen hunderte
zimmer
von außen ist es schwer zu sagen was für
einen zweck das gebäude hatte auch wenn
man hineingeht bleibt das rätselhaft
der betonklotz überschattet dieses
kleine fischerdorf im nirgendwo förmlich
warum wurde er ausgerechnet dort gebaut
die naturgewalten haben das gebäude
stark in mitleidenschaft gezogen
jedes jahr fallen dort sechs meter
schnee ein vielfaches mehr als der
landesdurchschnitt
die kälte und der wind haben dem bau
über die jahre sicher zugesetzt
aber er ist sehr massiv hier muss also
noch etwas anderes stärkeres am werk
gewesen sein
der mysteriöse komplex entsteht während
des ost west konflikts
er soll dazu beitragen einen atomkrieg
zu verhindern und hält später einer
verheerenden
naturkatastrophe stand
was heute wie bedeutungslose einöde
wirkt wird vor rund 80 jahren zu einem
dreh und angelpunkt der weltpolitik
vor 1940 lebten nur wenige menschen in
ried er als der zweite weltkrieg
ausbrach wurde alaska plötzlich relevant
die usa befürchteten dass die japaner
sie dort angreifen könnten
als reaktion erhöht das us militär seine
präsenz in den bundesstaat
auch nach dem krieg bleibt alaska ein
strategisch wichtiger posten im
aufkeimenden konflikt mit der
sowjetunion
denn keine 100 jahre zuvor war alaska
noch eine russische kolonie
das gebiet hatte lange zeit den russen
gehört bevor die amerikaner es ihnen
1867 abkauften
doch was hat das mit dem betonbau zu tun
im westen grenzt alaska an die
beringstraße die rund 80 kilometer
breite meerenge trend nordamerika von
der sowjetunion
wir betrachten diese länder oft als
gegenpole am jeweils anderen ende der
welt aber wenn man die perspektive
wechselt sind sie praktisch nachbarn
als die spannungen zwischen den
supermächten im kalten krieg zu nehmen
drückt alaska als mögliches ziel eines
sowjetischen angriffs in den fokus
[Musik]
was wenn die sowjets in alaska
einmarschiert werden das wäre äußerst
unbequem für die amerikaner gewesen
wäre das worst case szenario gewesen
sowjetische truppen landen in alaska und
können von dort aus raketen abfeuern und
flugzeuge starten lassen die usa hätten
den gegner direkt vor der haustür gehabt
heute erscheint so ein einmarsch
vielleicht abwegig doch nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg trauen sich beide parteien
keinen zentimeter über den weg
1949 zündet die sowjetunion erstmals
eine atombombe auf einem testgelände in
kasachstan eine klare provokation für
die amerikaner
im jahr darauf unterstützen diese jetzt
die nordkoreaner bei deren einmarsch in
südkorea
zeitgleich kommen in china und dammer
ausführung die kommunisten an die macht
die usa fühlen sich bedroht von der
totalitären ideologie die sich in asien
wie ein lauffeuer zu verbreiten scheint
als reaktion darauf errichten sie 1950
einen militärstützpunkt in alaska zu dem
auch das bugner building gehört
die einrichtung soll eine wichtige
funktion im kalten krieg erfüllen
brender turnen lebt seit langem in
medias und kennt die bewegte geschichte
des betonbaus
[Musik]
das gebäude entstand anfang der 50er
jahre und gegen 1960 außer betrieb es
wurde also seit rund 60 jahren nicht
instand gehalten und steht trotzdem noch
als das partner building in whittier
geplant wird sind die usa dabei ihre
streitkräfte massiv zu vergrößern die
anlage soll ein ganzes bataillon
beherbergen 1000 mann
damals war es das größte gebäude in
alaska
es ist sehr weitläufig und hat neben den
sechs etagen noch ein geheimes
untergeschoss
[Musik]
dort lebten soldaten medizinisches
personal
sicherheitsleute und militärpolizisten
es gab unterkünfte eine kantine ein kino
einen schießstand und sogar eine
bowlingbahn
bei den meisten stützpunkten sind diese
einrichtungen über ein größeres gelände
verteilt hier war alles unter einem dach
auf 25.000 quadratmetern betreibt das us
amerikanische militär eine komplette
kleinstadt in den betonbunker
niemand muss vor die tür gehen um etwas
zu erledigen
[Musik]
in der gegend fällt sehr viel schnee
da macht es sinn alles im selben gebäude
zu haben
das packen building muss den rauen
wetterbedingungen in alaska dauerhaft
trotzen
mit ihr wurde gegründet weil die bucht
selbst im winter nicht zufriert von hier
aus gelangen schiffs güter per eisenbahn
ins hinterland alaska versorgt sich zu
95 prozent durch importe knapp die
hälfte davon passiert wird er
das war die wichtigste versorgungs linie
der us-truppen in alaska soldaten waffen
ausrüstung alles kamen mit ihr an der
hafen musste jederzeit an steuerbar sein
um die operation nicht zu gefährden
mit hilfe des backnanger building machen
die amerikaner alaska zu einem
wachposten am sogenannten ice vorhang je
größer die gefahr eines sowjetischen
angriff scheint desto wichtiger wird der
stützpunkt
im kalten krieg befürchtete man dass ein
atom raketenangriff auf die usa über die
beringstraße und somit über alaska
hinweg erfolgen würde
die amerikaner bauen eine tausende
kilometer lange kette von radarstationen
um feindliche flugzeuge aus zu machen
bevor sie die amerikanische küste
erreichen einige dieser anlagen stehen
in alaska
ohne sie hätte man einen angriff aus
dieser richtung erst so spät erkannt
dass kaum zeit gewesen wäre um zu
reagieren mit möglicherweise
katastrophalen folgen
die radarstationen können nur betrieben
werden solange das bugner building in
whittier die versorgung sicherstellt
die ganze konstruktion war extrem stabil
dicke betonwände ein solides fundament
der bau sollte alles überstehen können
sowohl die sowjets als auch das harte
klima
doch gegen den fortschritt ist er nicht
gewappnet bereits ende der 50er jahre
hat sich die waffentechnologie stark
weiterentwickelt mit
interkontinentalraketen könnte die
sowjetunion über tausende kilometer
hinweg angreifen
wozu also diesen riesigen stützpunkt
mitten im nirgendwo weiter betreiben
1960 gibt die us army das bugner
building auf seinen härtetest erlebt das
gebäude vier jahre später
allerdings sind es nicht die sowjets die
ihn zu setzen sondern die naturgewalten
[Musik]
das bis dahin stärkste erdbeben in der
geschichte der usa traf mit
9,2 auf der richterskala ein 13 meter
hoher tsunami insgesamt 139 tote davon
13 in wedding wo der boden drei
geschlagene minutenlang erzitterte blieb
das bugner building stehen kaum zu
glauben ein richtig solider bau
die restliche stadt lag praktisch in
trümmern
aber inmitten der zerstörung hatte der
beton komplex allen widrigkeiten
standgehalten
[Musik]
bis heute steht das partner building
verlassen in der 200 seelen gemeinde und
zeugt von den erbitterten wettrüsten der
supermächte im kalten krieg
[Musik]
in sevilla im südwesten spaniens liegt
ein gelände voller seltsamer
konstruktionen
man findet dort allerhand skurrile
gebilde etwa eine rakete und etwas das
an eine gigantische satellitenschüssel
erinnert
da ist ein bahnsteig ein riesiger globus
und eine brücke die ins nichts zu führen
scheint
fast so als hätte ein kind diese
fantastische stadt erschaffen und dann
irgendwann gelangweilt sein spielzeug
auf dem boden liegen lassen
das gelände ist nicht komplett verlassen
teile davon sind immer noch in betrieb
auf der einen seite haben wir diese leer
stehenden verrückten gebäude und auf der
anderen seite ein lebendiges junges
umfeld in dem es von menschen nur so
wimmelt
man kann sich nur schwer einen reim
darauf bilden was das ganze sein soll
und warum einige teile erhalten wurden
andere aber nicht
[Musik]
heute bietet die anlage einen
ungewöhnlichen mix aus alt und neu
doch als sie 1992 fertiggestellt wird
ist sie ein strahlendes symbol der
hoffnung und des fortschritts in sevilla
nach francos tod kam es in den 70er
jahren zu einem umfassenden wandel in
spanien
aus der diktatur wurde ein
demokratischer staat ganz ohne
revolution oder gewalt
und von visa wiedergeburt soll jeder
erfahren dass neue spanien will sich
nach der transaktion offen und
zukunftsgerichtet präsentieren
das land boomt im laufe der 80er jahre
hatte es sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch
kulturell auf bis es schließlich wieder
zur obersten riege in europa und
weltweit gehörte
die wieder erstarkte nation rückt in den
mittelpunkt des welt interesses eine
entscheidende rolle spielt dabei das
rätselhafte gelände in zivil
1992 wollte spanien ein zeichen setzen
das land wollte der ganzen welt zeigen
dass es einen neuanfang gewagt hatte und
in der moderne angekommen war
dies ist das gelände der weltausstellung
expo
eine expo auszurichten heißt nach vorne
zu blicken visionen für die zukunft zu
entwickeln und allen zu zeigen wie viel
potenzial man hat daran werden sich alle
erinnern
die ausstellung dauert nicht bloß einen
tag oder eine woche sondern ein halbes
jahr sie hinterlässt einen bleibenden
eindruck bei millionen von besuchern
spanien war stolz auf seine entwicklung
und das sollten alle sehen die botschaft
war seht her wir sind wieder da und
spielen ganz vorne mit
die pavillons auf dem
ausstellungsgelände werden nach einem
konzept gestaltet dass die perfekte
bühne bietet das thema der expo 92 ist
das zeitalter der entdeckungen
diese konstruktionen hier sollen das
thema widerspiegeln damals feierte man
den 510 jahrestag der entdeckung
amerikas durch christoph kolumbus im
auftrag der spanier
gleichzeitig wollte sich spanien als
modernes zukunftsgerichtetes land mit
pioniergeist präsentieren
vor diesem hintergrund macht die
ansammlung wie zara bauten plötzlich
sinn
es sollte die größte expo werden wie es
bis dahin gab mehr als 100 nationen
beteiligen sich an der weltausstellung
und gestalten pavillons auf dem gelände
in sevilla
das komplexe großprojekt mit seinen
vielen teilnehmern unterliegt einem
engen zeitplan
[Musik]
man könnte sagen dass die spanier sich
ein wenig übernommen hatten ein projekt
dieser größenordnung umzusetzen ist ein
alptraum nicht zuletzt weil der
eröffnungstermin als deadline
unverrückbar ist
sie wollten zu viel in zu kurzer zeit
das hat zu problemen geführt
die gastgeber planen selbst eine ganze
reihe von attraktionen wie etwa den
zukunfts pavillon aber unter zeitdruck
läuft das ein oder andere gehöre schief
kurz vor der eröffnung stand der index
pavillon in flammen auf den letzten
metern mussten viele arbeiten
gleichzeitig passieren maler und
schweizer waren parallel am werk so kam
es dass ein funke einen farbeimer traf
der dann feuer fing
innerhalb kürzester zeit umgeben dichte
rauchwolken den pavillon der traum von
der export droht vor dem aus zu stehen
doch die feuerwehr bringt in brand unter
kontrolle und die ausstellung kann
stattfinden
[Musik]
trotz einiger anlaufschwierigkeiten war
die expo ein großer erfolg die
besucherzahlen brachen alle rekorde und
spanien konnte zeigen was ist erreicht
hatte
jeden tag kamen rund
240.000 besucher um über das gelände zu
spazieren und sich all die
beeindruckenden bauten anzuschauen was
für ein unglaublicher erfolg
insgesamt 41 millionen menschen besuchen
die ausstellung
viele von ihnen erreichen das gelände
über diesen kanal der damals noch wasser
führt
man konnte mit dem boot her kommen mit
der seilbahn oder einfach zu fuß über
eine der brücken die das gelände an die
stadt anbinden und die besucher schauten
sich die verschiedenen pavillons an und
schlenderten von einem zum nächsten
der erfolg der expo übertrifft alle
erwartungen
spanien hat sein ziel erreicht sich der
welt in neuem licht zu präsentieren
aber was passiert mit dem gelände als
die ausstellung schließt
nach einer expo hat das
veranstaltungsgelände ausgedient
übrig bleibt eine architektonische
spielwiese was das gastgeberland damit
macht ist ihm überlassen
oft bleiben die ausstellungsflächen
weitgehend ungenutzt und verfallen doch
nicht in zivil
luis perez ist der innovationsmanager
der anlage
damals beschloss man ein projekt ins
leben zu rufen und die anlage als
wissenschafts und technologiepark wieder
aufleben zu lassen
im laufe der jahre wurden einige gebäude
abgerissen und durch neue ersetzt
andere wurden saniert
zurzeit sind 460 firmen im
technologiepark ansässig
das projekt ist sehr erfolgreich in ein
paar jahren werden wir das gesamte
gelände nutzen
ein kleiner umzäunten bereich ist
bislang unberührt geblieben denn die
markantesten wahrzeichen werden so lange
es geht erhalten
die menschen in sevilla schätzen diese
wahrzeichen sie müssen nicht
umfunktioniert werden weil sie für viele
leute eine bedeutung haben
die rakete und die satellitenschüssel
sind wohl die bekanntesten
irgendwann werden sicher auch sie teil
des technologieparks werden dann wird
das ganze expo gelände wieder so
lebendig sein wie damals
in der eifel an der grenze zu belgien
führt eine linie aus beton szenen mitten
durch den wald
[Musik]
wenn man die ersten blöcke entdeckt
denkt man dass die reihe vielleicht ein
paar dutzend meter lang ist
die papst doch dann stellt man fest dass
sie immer und immer weiter geht
man spaziert durch den wald oder die
felder und findet hier und da seltsame
spuren aus einer vergangenen zeit
[Musik]
die überreste erinnern an ein dunkles
kapitel der deutschen geschichte
[Musik]
als ich das erste mal hier war hatte ich
ein unheimliches gefühl
wir haben sich regelrecht die
nackenhaare aufgestellt
die beton zähne sind nicht die einzigen
relikte in der gegend dutzende
verfallener strukturen zeugen von den
kämpfen die hier einst stattgefunden
haben
da sind überall diese betonbauten die
unter dem moos oder zwischen zweigen
hervorblitzen wenn man sie findet fragt
man sich welchen zweck sie erfüllt haben
auf beton der verfallen und abgebröckelt
ist aber diese bauten wurden war etwas
sehr schweren getroffen immer und immer
wieder deshalb sehen sie so zertrümmert
aus
was verbindet die ruinen in der eifel
und warum sind sie in diesem zustand
die hacker linie auch drachen oder
hitler zähne genannt ist teil des
westwalls
der diktator liest das
verteidigungssystem vor dem zweiten
weltkrieg an der westgrenze des
deutschen reichs errichten
scheinbar endlose reihen von
betonklötzen flankiert von bunkern und
unterständen
drachen zähne sind panzersperren aus
beton jeder dieser höcker ist in beton
gegossen und mit stahl verstärkt
zudem ist er mit den anderen um ihn
herum verbunden man kann sie also nicht
einfach herausreißen der
einzige weg sie zu überwinden ist eine
lücke hinein zu sprengen und selbst das
ist schwierig
mit der hacker linie wollte hitler
feindliche panzer angriffe abwehren auf
ebenso einfache wie wirksame weise
die zähne sind unterschiedlich hoch wenn
die panzer darüber fahren können
panzerabwehr kanoniere angreifbare
unterseite treffen
der westwall erstreckt sich über mehr
als 600 kilometer von der
niederländischen grenze bis zur
schweizer grenze im süden deutschlands
der westwall von den alliierten
siegfried linie genannt war keine
durchgehende verteidigungslinie manche
abschnitte waren stark befestigt mit
bunkern und panzersperren andere
abschnitte im bergigen gelände dagegen
kaum
überall dort wo ein angriff drohen
könnte platzieren die nazis drachen
szene manchmal in mehreren linien
hintereinander doch die panzersperren
allein reichen nicht zur abwehr sie sind
teil eines komplexen
verteidigungssystems aus bunkern stollen
und gräben
der westwall war mehr als ein langes
stück höcker linie
drachen zähne bringen nur etwas wenn
dahinter bunker und panzer abwehr
kanonen warten
zum westwall gehörten 18.000 stellungen
manche abschnitte wiesen mehrere
verteidigungslinien mit verschiedenen
befestigungen auf die kilometer weit ins
hinterland reichten
1938 will hitler in einem propagandafilm
die vermeintliche unbezwingbarkeit des
westwalls zur schau stellen
er ließ es so aussehen als wäre der
westwall vergleichbar mit der
französischen maschine linie
dabei war er nicht annähernd so stark
befestigt und alles andere als
unbezwingbar
als propaganda erfüllte der film seinen
zweck peter wollte die deutschen auf den
bevorstehenden krieg einstimmen er
nährte die mär dass sie schutz vor den
feindlichen nachbarländern brauchten
als hitler seinen feldzug durch halb
europa beginnt spielt verteidigung
anfangs jedoch keine große rolle mit der
blitzkrieg taktik nimmt der polen und
frankreich jeweils innerhalb weniger
wochen ein die wehrmacht scheint
unaufhaltsam also werden waffen und
anderes material vom westwall an die
front geschickt
am ende des krieges haben die deutschen
den westphal allerdings doch gebraucht
wenn auch anders als hitler vorher
gesehen hatte nachdem die alliierten am
d day in der normandie gelandet waren
rückten sie in richtung des rheins vor
und die wehrmacht nutzte den westwall
als verteidigungslinie
im herbst 1944 ziehen sich die deutschen
zurück hinter die mittlerweile schlecht
ausgestattete linie
sie verlegten truppen und hoben neue
schützengräben aus als die alliierten
den westwall erreichten war er
streckenweise wieder voll bewacht
an einigen stellen können die alliierten
truppen die feindlichen linien schnell
durchbrechen doch in manchen gebieten
entbrennen langwierige und verlustreiche
kämpfe
die schlacht im hürtgenwald war extrem
hat die nazis hatten sich in dicht
bewaldeten gebiet verschanzt
es war sehr schwer den feind auszumachen
geschweige denn artillerie einzusetzen
als einstige kaiserstadt hatte aachen
einen hohen symbolwert für die deutschen
deshalb verteidigten sie die stadt so
entschlossen mit ihren besten truppen
es gelang ihnen auch dank des schlechten
wetters der us army hohe verluste
zuzufügen
am 6 oktober 1944 unternehmen
us-einheiten einen vorstoß im
hürtgenwald
doch die deutschen machen sich die
verteidigungsmöglichkeiten des westwalls
zunutze
[Musik]
nicht jeder meter einer so lang
gezogenen linie muss unbezwingbar sein
im gegenteil wenn die alliierten an
einem schwächer befestigten abschnitt
durchbrechen könnten sie im mehrstufigen
deutschen stellungs system mit seinen
vielen versteckten bunker steckenbleiben
der hürtgenwald und das gelände um
aachen herum sind sehr hügelig mit
vielen schluchten
perfekt um angreifer in eine bestimmte
richtung zu locken
an schlüsselstellen sind die drachen
zähne in mehreren reihen hintereinander
platziert um einem feindlichen vorstoß
das tempo zunehmen
dahinter warten mg schützen in bunkern
und unterständen darauf die vorrückenden
soldaten auszuschalten
die voraussetzung dafür eine
reibungslose kommunikation
in front
das hier ist einer von 18.000 bunkern
die zum westwall gehört haben
der diente als kommando und
kommunikations bunker von dem aus andere
stellungen mit informationen zu den
feindlichen truppenbewegungen versorgt
wurden
die us army bekommt die wirksamkeit des
deutschen verteidigungssystems in voller
härte zu spüren
die amerikaner kämpften sich mühsam
durch den hürtgenwald viele verloren
dabei ihr leben
was sie haben diese dicht bewachsenen
hügel erklommen oft unter schlimmsten
wetterbedingungen es hat viel geregnet
in jenem herbst die männer stiegen im
nebel hoch und plötzlich tauchte ein mg
nest auf und sie gerieten unter beschuss
zwei monate lang liefern sich amerikaner
und deutsche eine kräftezehrende
schlacht
zehntausende sterben im hürtgenwald
dann setzt hitler zu einem
überraschenden gegenschlag an im zuge
der ardennenoffensive soll die wehrmacht
bis antwerpen vorstoßen und den hafen
einnehmen so soll sie die
nachschublinien der westalliierten
stören und deren vormarsch stilllegen
im morgengrauen des 16 dezember 1944
rücken die deutschen truppen vor
überrumpelt ziehen sich die alliierten
zurück sie können die überdehnten front
abschnitte nicht halten hitlers
aberwitziger plan scheint aufzugehen
doch schon nach wenigen tagen geht den
deutschen kanzlern der treibstoff aus
und die offensive gerät ins stocken
den amerikanern und briten gelingt es
die wehrmacht erneut zurück zu bringen
die deutschen streitkräfte an der
westfront sind inzwischen massiv
geschwächt sie haben viel material
eingebüßt fast 70.000 soldaten sind
gefallen verwundet oder vermisst
im märz 1945 durchbrechen die alliierten
die letzten von den deutschen gehaltenen
teile des westwalls und überqueren den
rhein
zu dem zeitpunkt war die wehrmacht nicht
mehr in der lage groß angelegte
verteidigungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen der
weg nach berlin würde also leichter
werden
heute sind große teile von hitlers
westphal zerstört oder abgerissen die
schlachten die dort gekämpft worden
haben den weg für einen geeinten europa
bereitet
wenn man über diese schlachtfelder geht
wird einem klar welchen aufwand hitler
betrieben hat um den westwall zu
errichten das zeigt neben vielen anderen
dingen wie größenwahnsinnig seine pläne
waren eine wichtige lektion der
geschichte
diese bunker erinnern an den zweiten
weltkrieg es ist wichtig die geschichte
nicht einfach zu vergessen
im herzen ungarns in der hauptstadt
budapest liegt ein stählernes gerippe
diese werkhallen sind kurz davor
endgültig einzustürzen sie wirken als
könne sie schon der kleinste windhauch
umstoßen
teile bröckelt von den wänden fenster
sind zerschmettert als würde das alles
seit ewigkeiten vor sich hin rotten
dies sind die überreste des
bahnbetriebswerks ist pantelic und sie
bergen ein düsteres geheimnis
darin steckt fast ein jahrhundert
eisenbahngeschichte
die damalige wirtschaftliche und
politische lage in ungarn spiegelt sich
dort wieder
in den hallen stehen lokomotiven waggons
und allerhand zubehör
als ob jemand das ganze zeug weggesperrt
und den schlüssel weggeworfen hätte aber
jetzt können wir hinein
[Musik]
auf zugewucherten gleisen stehen
rostiger eisenbahnwaggons die an ein
dunkles kapitel in der ungarischen
geschichte erinnern
vor dem zweiten weltkrieg hatte eine
rechtsextreme regierung das land in eine
fatale abhängigkeit zu nazi deutschland
gebracht und
1944 besetzten die deutschen ungarn
schließlich und ließen massenhaft juden
deportieren sie wurden mit zügen in
konzentrationslager gebracht aus denen
sie nie wiederkehren sollten
weit mehr als eine halbe million
ungarische juden sterben während der
kriegsjahre und die eisenbahn erfüllt
dabei einen teuflischen zweck
einige dieser waggons sind vom gleichen
typ wie jene mit denen die juden in die
lager deportiert wurden
dort erwartete die meisten ein grausamer
tod vielleicht sind es sogar dieselben
wagen
nach dem krieg geriet ungarn unter
sowjetischen einfluss und damit auch das
bahnbetriebswerk in budapest die anlage
entstand anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts und wurde im laufe der zeit
erweitert
chandor tibor hat hier einst als
ingenieur gearbeitet
das war die schmiedewerkstatt
sie wurde in den 20er jahren gebaut und
viele der ungarischen dampfloks wurden
hier repariert und gewartet
das straßennetz war lange zeit in weiten
teilen unter entwickelt mit dem ausbau
des schienennetzes im neunzehnten
jahrhundert hatten sich neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet produktion
gütertransport personenverkehr all das
hatte sich durch die eisenbahn verändert
dabei spielen die mav lokomotiven der
ungarischen staatsbahn eine zentrale
rolle
rada ungarn keinen zugang zum meer hat
werden die meisten güter per zug
transportiert die mav lokomotiven waren
sehr schnell
auch personenzüge erreichten mit ihnen
hohe geschwindigkeiten
heute sind die werkhallen im stadtteil
ist warnte lag bei touristen meist unter
einem anderen namen bekannt
[Musik]
eine der lokomotiven trägt ein symbol
das eng mit der geschichte um ganz nach
dem krieg verbunden ist und im ort
seinen spitznamen verleiht eisenbahn
friedhof roter stern
der rote stern war ein symbol der
sowjetunion und praktisch überall zu
finden
das allgegenwärtige zeichen eines
totalitären regimes das seine satelliten
staaten an der kurzen leine hält
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg war die udssr
wirtschaftlich stark geschwächt also
nahm sie sich alles an produktions
gütern aus osteuropa was sie gebrauchen
konnte
der schienenfahrzeuge wurden einfach
beschlagnahmt und in die sowjetunion
gebracht
ein herber schlag für das land das
massiv auf seine eisenbahn angewiesen
ist die ausbeutung und unterdrückung
durch die sowjetischen machthaber führt
die unzufriedenheit in der ungarischen
bevölkerung
und gipfelt schließlich in offenem
widerstand ingenieur josef deag weiß wie
hart der nachkriegsjahre waren
das eisenbahnnetz musste dringend
saniert werden ohne den güterverkehr
wäre das halbe land zum erliegen
gekommen die schiene war wie eine
lebensader
ungarn hat im zweiten weltkrieg ein
viertel aller industriestandorte
eingebüßt
nach dem krieg stürzt die wirtschaft in
die inflation trotz umfangreicher
reformen durch die kommunisten bleibt
den armen des landes kaum genug um über
die runden zu kommen viele leiden hunger
die sowjetunion verhielt sich gegenüber
ihren satelliten staaten wie eine
kolonialmacht
das regime erwartete dass die
ostblockstaaten ihre wirtschaft schnell
wieder zum laufen brachten wenn jemand
die produktionsziele nicht erreichte
könnte derjenige mir nichts dir nichts
aus dem weg geschafft und durch einen
stellvertreter ersetzt werden
die bahn werkstatt war wesentlich für
die bemühungen die wirtschaft wieder in
gang zu bringen
[Musik]
die anlage in budapest war so wichtig
weil es damals keine vergleichbare in
der region gab
später kamen noch andere dazu aber
zunächst war das die einzige werkstatt
in der große dampflokomotiven repariert
und gewartet werden konnten
doch als josef stalin 1953 an einem
schlaganfall stirbt beginnt es im land
zu brodeln viele ungarn sehen den tod
des sowjetischen diktators als chance
sich aus den fesseln seines regimes zu
befreien in budapest braut sich eine
revolution zusammen die dem regime in
moskau gefährlich werden kann
der alte tyrannen stalin war tot und
viele ungarn hofften dass irland nun
wieder auf eigenen füßen stehen und
liberaler werden würde
die regime treuen regierungen der
ostblock staaten versuchten jeden
widerstand im keim zu ersticken
dennoch kam es im oktober 1956 zum
volksaufstand
der staatssicherheitsdienst feuerte auf
die demonstranten vor dem
parlamentsgebäude
danach kam es zu heftigen kämpfen die
sowjetische besatzung armee bekommt
verstärkung aus der udssr um den
volksaufstand niederzuschlagen
ein großteil der truppen kommt mit zügen
1956 waren die streitkräfte das auch
jetzt noch nicht voll motorisiert sie
waren auch die eisenbahn angewiesen
die ungarische eisenbahn trug
unfreiwillig dazu bei die sowjetische
besatzung aufrecht zu erhalten die armee
hat den volksaufstand brutal
niedergeschlagen fast 3000 ungarn kamen
ums leben mehr als 200.000 flohen in den
westen
ungarn bleibt bis zum fall des eisernen
vorhangs über 30 jahre später unter
kommunistischem einfluss die
dampflokomotiven werden jedoch nach und
nach von dieselloks abgelöst die
deutlich wartungsärmer sind
damit verliert auch das betriebswerk ist
warnte lag an bedeutung
bis heute findet man dort die relikte
der bewegten geschichte ungarns
[Musik]
die halle und die züge darin sehen aus
als wären sie durch die hölle gegangen
das zwanzigste jahrhundert war eine
aneinanderreihung von wirtschaftlichen
herausforderungen und furchtbaren
kriegen die spuren davon sehen wir dort
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte höher war sie könnten von
krieg und terror von erfindergeist und
dem streben nach fortschritt
[Musik]